Las Vegas Nevada where folks from all
over the world descend upon for gambling
buffets and this week The Flash movie
hidden theater so we're on the street
asking people are you excited to see the
flash or that bat fella that might show
up let's meet some people on the street
[Music]
no all mice have seen the trailer for
that
I don't know I don't know anything about
it's flash a flash in England is a a
brand of cleaning products it's a
cleaning product and Flash is low on the
superheroes for me
[Music]
hi I love you that will be exciting I
miss a flash heavy so I'm really
motivated to flash great flash fan I'm a
big DC fan bro I like Batman Superman
the Flash would be the flash is a great
character I saw the trailer and then
they did the reveal with uh oh my God
are you yes I'm Batman yeah
I'm Batman it's gonna be a reboot right
they're gonna use this as an opportunity
to redo the entire DC Universe so it's
gonna be pretty mind-blowing I want to
see how they're gonna do it I've been a
comic book movie fan for a really long
time I mean they can tend to go one of
two ways they're either fantastic or
disgraceful so I'm gonna hope for
fantastic but not uh you know get my
hopes too high I'm not too much of a
Marvels fan this is DC it's a whole
different comic book property so there
you go
[Music]
thank you
Michael Keaton is going to be Batman
again are you serious is he that's great
oh that is dope no way guess what
oh wow okay okay well I mean my
expectations are raised now I mean come
on you want to get nuts
let's get nuts that's really cool
reminds me of that uh Spider-Man movie
that did not too long ago like had Toby
McGuire coming back it is really nice to
uh and refreshing to see Keaton return
and for DC to so beautifully copy the
latest Spider-Man movie let's just bring
back all the favorite characters and
we'll make it Canon I love to hear OG
he's my favorite Batman yeah it's pretty
nice to see him back in action after
what 30 some years 30 some years we were
all so young I didn't exist 30 years ago
but
you don't like Michael Keaton as Batman
I don't like Michael penis Batman not as
Batman no okay how about his Beetlejuice
perfect Batman not so much
no
flash for sure both man both man I love
Batman
it's like you don't want to hurt the
Flash's feelings
I'm definitely looking for Batman I've
always been a Batman fan Batman Batman
yeah Batman Batman's gonna be up there I
mean for Batman probably realistically
right for the warm and breaks of
nostalgia you know that we all Crave in
these troubling times I just want to see
all of them and see you know whether
it's a train wreck or whether it's gonna
be the next set Flash the cleaning
products are you a professional maid I
wait I wish I had that dream okay well I
I think I know which cleaning product
you're going to be sponsored by
I'm Batman I'm Batman I'm Batman I'm
Batman I'm Batman I'm Batman I'm Batman
I'm Batman you hear that growl I'm
Batman well actually that's that's the
best I got for you he doesn't say I'm
Batman well actually
I'm Batman I'm Batman now you're gonna
be doing it all day right I'm dead man
it's going up to random people in Vegas
saying I'm Batman I'm Batman I'm Batman
I think she won I think she beats a shot
give us another goal I'm Batman
[Music]
as always thanks for tuning in to Rotten
Tomatoes subscribe to this YouTube
channel hit that Bell it'll give you a
notification every time we got a new vid
dropping and of course leave a comment
below tell us how you feel and we'll see
you next time right here at Rotten
Tomatoes after you check out the Flash
in theaters make sure you rate and
review at rottentomatoes.com okay so we
found out today that in the UK flash
isn't necessarily a superhero so much as
a cleaning product we saw the cleaning
project 10 out of 10. you're really good
at this you're gonna take my job happy
Birthday Chris thank you hey that was
great man